so how is the media reacting how is the
corporate press which was all about
people getting fired and all about
people getting censored and all about
people complying and not all about
people protesting and not all about
people exercising their free speech how
are they feeling about this this leak
right now how are they feeling about the
fact that we know that an FBI lawyer was
censoring documents that Elon Musk was
trying to release to the people he's
going around mainstream media that's
what this is really about what the Side
Story to all of this is not just the
information that we're learning about
the coordination the Side Story is that
Elon did not release the Twitter files
to CNN or to the New York Times or to
Washington Post or even the Wall Street
Journal he released it to Matt taibi who
is an independent journalist he released
it to Barry Weiss who is an independent
journalist by the way they both happen
to be left leading taibi I think now
he's kind of coming around to this side
let's say but he was a huge huge
Progressive left 35 six years ago and
Barry you guys know I have certain
frustrations with her but she's still
basically a lefty Democrat like I would
argue very muddled and confused about
all the issues it's not like he brought
the information to Crazy freaking Ben
Shapiro and Glenn Beck right he gave it
to lefties but the point is it doesn't
matter who he gives it to they're going
to try to take him out because he didn't
give it to them here's CNN's Christine
Romans saying that now this stuff that's
not a big deal
look somewhere else no what some wants
you to think is that this was censorship
by big Tech and that's why the president
is saying you should throw out the
Constitution because big Tech is in
cahoots with American democracy that's
what the president thinks but what it
sort of shows is a real struggle at an
important platform for how to deal with
something so outrageous so explosive and
and what to actually do with it what
pointer said which is an immediate
Watchdog group they said um file this
one under file the Twitter files under M
for Ma and the Washington Post said
there are no no smoking gun here God so
this lady on CNN basically says this is
nothing and then she refers to a website
pointer which is a media Watchdog which
no doubt gets Lefty money like it's just
obvious and what are they saying ah it's
not much what's Washington Post saying
owned by another billionaire right what
are they saying and nothing to look at
do you guys think it's nothing to look
at but man they can confuse you about
everything so the average person and we
just have to accept it you know these
people I don't want to get rid of them I
don't want to silence them I don't want
to take away their voting rights or kick
them out of the country but we have to
ex we have to accept and I think the
last election is proof of it we have to
accept that a certain amount of people
just by the state line they just are
non-playable characters that's the NPC
meme they just if they hear something
that's how it is mainstream set it so
that's how it is sure six months later
two years later you know 60 Minutes will
acknowledge that the hunter Biden laptop
is real after uh they told Donald Trump
to his face that it's not real and they
can't cover it but that's all right and
that's why I keep saying the truth is a
Time release pill these days that's what
we're finding out